attention aux prénoms que vous donnez à
vos enfants depuis 1993 en france on
peut choisir n'importe quel prénom et ne
pas se contenter du calendrier officiel
alors sont en train de fleurir les
l'oréal chanel ikea ou encore
périphériques pour une petite fille née
dernièrement sur ce boulevard du même
nom cela peut sembler très drôle au
départ mais très perturbant par la suite
pour l'enfant ban et sarouels aux
banques
le premier cri la première respiration
auquel il va falloir donner un prénom
ils y allaient très tendance héloïse
dylan les halles lucas ou périphériques
autoroute le pourquoi tu as fait sourire
mais le n'importe quoi est légal depuis
la loi de 1993
l'officier d'état civil doit
obligatoirement inscrire le prénom
choisi par les parents
pikachu contre goldorak l'imagination
semble mal à dire si j'ai envie
d'appeler mon enfant lampadaires j'ai
des chances vous avez des chances alors
tout dépend aussi de la réaction de
l'officier d'état civil
il n'y a pas à vous de prouver qu' il
n'y a pas de côté péjoratif à ce prénom
après les zébulons et autres albator le
très chic décalé à la mode ce sont les
marques déjà 500 chanel en france et 3
ikea sur les trois qui le portent le
caire en france ikea a été choisi parce
qu'ils ont eu énormément de mal à avoir
cette enfant au même titre qu'ils
avaient eu énormément de mal à monter
les meubles porteur de sens de vécu tout
prénom peut être aussi facteur de
traumatisme moral une réalité ignorée ou
refoulés par certains parents je m'amuse
à donner n'importe quel prénom à mon
enfant et on ne réalise pas ensuite
comme un adolescent s'est même petit en
classe avec les moqueries
ce sera parfois très difficile à porter
pour un enfant donc il faudrait quand
même penser vraiment à votre enfant à
tous les âges de sa vie où commence le
préjudice où s'arrête l'originalité
depuis le 11 septembre 2001 200 bambins
en france se prénomme oussama
en hongrie